côté terrain maintenant parisiens et
marseillais ont préparé activement cette
finale les dernières rencontres entre
les deux clubs n'ont pas laissé un
souvenir impérissable aux amoureux du
beau jeu de mains et les deux formations
les plus populaires de france ont
l'occasion de se racheter aussi de
montrer l'exemple à leurs supporteurs
notamment de rincquesen laisse mater les
départs d'un bon sentiment
des supporteurs de l'om au camp des
loges le fief du psg pour parler d'amour
entre les deux clubs
trop beau pour être vrai ce sont de faux
marseillais de vrais comédiens
il travaille pour une chaîne de
télévision cette discussion n'en demeure
pas moins révélatrice de la tension qui
règne entre les deux clubs
les supporteurs sont à cran il faut dire
que depuis dix ans les rencontres entre
l'om et le psg sont davantage marquée
par la violence que par les belles
actions
joueurs supporters dirigeants demain
soir la finale de la coupe de france
lors de l'occasion de se racheter et
rivalité entre les deux clubs on le sait
tout le monde le connaît bon après je
pense que c'est aussi la plus belle
fille là le qu'on puisse espérer dans le
microcosme du football français donc
cette finale pourrait sauver la saison
du psg à l'entraînement les parisiens
ont poussé le détail jusqu'à travaillé
les tirs au but avec l'om on n'est
jamais trop prudent sur moi je très
important
la mai prochain ses idées pour arriver à
ses fins paris compte sur le populaire
pauleta obligé de toutes les attentions
tant chez ses supporteurs que chez ses
adversaires c'est un très bon joueur il
manque deux beaux buts et il en ressort
qu à paris dans un état porte l'équipe à
lui seul tout à l'heure les joueurs de
l'om ont découvert la pelouse du stade
de france
une nouveauté pour cette équipe demain
marseille va disputer sa première
rencontre officielle dans cette enceinte
une rencontre qui se jouera à guichet
fermé